she tries to calm her down by playing
with her hair and it leads to something
a little bit more intimate we know this
isn't their first kiss but based on
need's reaction I'm guessing it may be
their second and the chemistry cannot be
understated you know the YouTube channel
movie clips the channel That Just posts
clips from pretty much every movie they
posted five clips from Jennifer's Body
but this kissing scene is by far the
most popular at the time of writing this
it has 419 million views making it the
fourth most watched movie clip of all
time the comment section just kind of
says it all special thanks to Fox and
Amanda Cipher for making my teenage
years 10 times more complicated with
this scene this scene is amazing you can
see how needi is slowly seduced by
Jennifer and how she gives in to some
hidden desire she had my hormone craze
teen self took 5 hours to finish this
movie uh you know what I I think we can
stop reading the comments